here we go are you ready I am real good
here at the end of the carpet you made
it I didn't make it through it's crazy
everyone wants a piece of you tonight
sorry we were so good thank you but
everyone was phenomenal and just walking
that carpet and seeing so many great
talents humble talents people I
appreciate and then you meet them and
people say don't meet your heroes but
I've met a few tonight and it's already
gorgeous the toasts pro/con so much
moet is going to donate $1000 in your
name to a charity of your choice
so what charity would you like us to
donate and toast to tonight of my choice
well seeing as how I'm representing
Freddie Mercury this evening let's do
the mercury Phoenix trust and take care
of everyone with or or anyone who knows
someone with HIV or AIDS let's get down
to business
you have only posted one Instagram post
a year for the last three years why I
need more of you I think it's so fun the
pressure I saw I saw
Timmy sha'lame in the bathroom and the
Palm Springs a war Film Festival the
other night and he just laughed so hard
at my three photos on Instagram what is
this role meant to you I mean you're a
front-runner for this award tonight
people are talking about you in the name
of Oscar I mean as an actor this is a
dream role but it means so much just so
many people that's exactly it
he means so much to so many people Queen
means so much to so many people their
music is timeless he is forever he's one
of the most authentic audacious bold
human beings ever to grace this earth
and he still manages to make people
people feel like they can be exactly who
they want to be he's made me feel that
way so cheers to Freddie cheers to Queen
is there anything that you learnt from
about yourself from playing him or
that he encapsulated that you took now
for the rest of your career that I can
be unabashedly myself and so can all of
us cheers to that
congratulations good luck
[Music]